hello and welcome to this video this is
a new instructional video and this part
of the middlegame serious yeah it
usually it's middle game strategy and
this time it's not so much about
strategy it's about a typical attacking
theme that happens really frequently
it's about them sacrifice on h7 often
called the Greek gift let's have a look
at some examples of that it's really
useful to have seen a couple of versions
of it seeing some finer points of it to
be better able to determine when to play
it and when to not play it I start with
a very basic example it's a game Yates
with white against player Marine evil
ovett not sure I'm pronouncing that
right from 1930 yeah it's out of a
French defense and actually the
sacrifice on h7 the Greek gift happens
quite frequently in the French defense
of black it's not very circumspect
because the basic pawn structure of the
French and this is this pawn structure
here against pawns on e6 95 a very good
yeah basic structure to get that
sacrifice working why is that because
these five porn does two things it
limits black here with this pawn on e6
that this Bishop cannot come out to help
in the defense and the e5 pawn is taking
away a porn square of six let's see how
that gets into work c5 Queen g4 by white
sand castles 93 and now white is really
threatening the ship takes h7 the
classic sacrifice black in that game was
completely unawares and went c4 after
vgh to college it's a token age 7 and
flag actually resigned now yeah there
you be at sequence
yeah why would you play c4 when you are
able to understand that after Bishop f7
you have to resign anyway let's have a
look at this why is this winning
sacrifice black takes what gives us Jack
King only has two and go back as no
other option and now 95 this is the
classic picture after the sacrifice on
h7 Queen and Knight from that attacking
duo threatening Queen h7 mate this is a
key thing there's the main threat on h7
and black in this example has no option
to cover that square the situation would
be entirely different if there wouldn't
be a pawn on e6 and Bishop f5 would be
possible then age 7 can be protected and
nothing much happens the other way to
defend against that check on h7 also
could be a knight coming to f6 yeah just
imagine I'm going to change the position
now a little bit to show you versions of
this just a moment now and now I change
the position a little bit black has a
night on d7 and now with no pawn on e5
he can play Knight to f6 and cover this
yeah unfortunately I haven't talked with
white to move which doesn't make much
sense yeah ok I'm going to change that
quick so Knight f6 yeah this is covering
this crucial square the same thing of
coverage of h7 can be accomplished by a
bishop or queen coming on that diagonal
yeah so let's again alter the position
slightly now here the e6 pawn is not
existing and Bishop s5 it's a check
that's quite funky ok but you get the
point
the bishop whatever I should have kept a
pawn on e5 the bishop camera said square
and therefore why there is no mating
idea yeah this is very important
resource
let's now quickly look at the actual
game to see how it finished so here why
took check-check
and now black cannot go be Chappell five
he cannot put a knight on f6 he has no
way to cover aged seven
so no pawn move will change any of that
the only way to prevent immediate mate
is to move the rook or give up the Queen
on g5 if you move the rocker just this
check this and black is mated note that
this Queen is obstructing blacks flight
square on e7 it's also very important
point like it's simply without any
defensive the only thing that you can do
is he can capture on g5 and play with
the Queen down against to two pieces
this is a classic version of the
sacrifice that works very in a very
straightforward way very often the
defense to to those some sacrifices can
be a little bit less obvious you know
sometimes there are defenses I'm going
to load a game now
yeah this is from a game that Kasparov
played in his youth and the late 70s
late 1970s and I got that oh this this
game was in the book that I was studying
together with the student and when we
reached this position in the book I gave
the following variation in the game the
black player played Bishop e7 and they
they say ok black cannot play Bishop b6
yeah the more active looking move
keeping that Bishop on an active
diagonal black cannot play that because
white can go for the classic gift
sacrifice
Bishop f7 e IG v Queen h5 and Queen f7
is going to seal the deal
note that rook e8 here it's a bit
different than in the example before
check because here actually black can't
escape with the King I mean white still
has a tremendous attack but it's a
different thing it's no checkmate
however this check is a very important
resource this is also hanging and yeah
yeah yeah checkmate it's a mate after
all so this is the Greeks gift Greek a
gift to sacrifice a book here or not
well when we looked at this my student
me we're looking wait what about the h7
square and queen d3 is indeed a move and
after that white can resign with the
clear conscience and there's absolutely
no check whatsoever yeah both are author
some of the book had overlooked this
little resource this is a book from the
pre-computer days where everything is
yeah blunder checked and yeah they
simply didn't it didn't see their move
so always check if there are defenses
that can cover the h7 square it's an
absolutely crucial point you usually
need really night on g5 Queen on h5 and
the
twenty-five and there's no cover of the
h7 square with Knight f6 Bishop f5 or in
this case a queen quite often those long
Queen moves I easily overlooked I think
it was just them I mean it happens okay
this is some some basic stuff about the
sacrifice quite often there is the
possibility to sacrifice and the lines
are not dead straightforward it still
works
but it is not as easy let's say to
understand us in the very first example
where the bishops sacrifice our
interests and was rather clearly winning
yeah that's a very nice example now of
the sacrifice in action where things are
not as straightforward not as clear as
in them as in the earlier example let's
have a look this is a game played in
1969 the Soviet championship back then
between left Poland I have ski white and
tar black yeah we all note I'll put our
ski is not so well known in comparison
he was a very strong player starting in
the late 60s 70s and 80s always been in
the world top 10 15 20 this kind of area
participated in some candidate matches
but he didn't get to the to the very top
he was a very inventive theoretician
amongst others inventing and having the
line named after him in the Sicilian
neither of the previous key variation
it's played a number of really great
games and this is one of his classics
and it is black to move in this position
and town are played the move Knight to
be to black is a pawn up here and now
tries with this double attack - Stu - to
exchange off White's dangerous bishop on
d3 yeah in fact he never got to take it
because now Czech bishop
seven was played let's check this
position how does this compare to the to
the other positions that we had before
um a big difference is I mean black
can't take it right this is the only
reasonable move a key difference is that
the queen is not coming to h5 yeah if in
this position by some miracle Queen to
h5 would be possible then queen h5 King
back Knight g5 would be as strong as in
the as in the games before made on h7 or
threatened if you can imagine that and
black really has no way to parry that in
some decent way he cannot cover h7 and
after Luke e8 there's again this Queen
f7 Queen h5 Queen f7 mechanism here
things are different the queen is on f4
which makes things a lot more
complicated the next new fear is of
course not g5 check in decline get this
Knight into the game with check so what
possibility is this black half he can
step forward and go back yeah the
easiest is it's the Kings after which
White has a chat check here check check
here check check check mate and mate
that's very neat yep King gets
completely chase down note that this
music it's not as clear because this is
a pin
the other continuation is just a force
maid if that goes to d8 we of course go
to h4 and this is very very comparable
to the Queen being on h5 the difference
is that after rookie aid we don't have
Queen f7 however check we have this
continuation and now is 6 this is very
strong using the rook also only one if
black now completely ignores everything
and just let's say takes the rook then
j7 is made next movement
checkmate very nice this is the big
threat if black takes check check check
we're winning at least the Queen
probably there's also made but if you
can take the Queen for not much it's
enough to be sure that you're winning
yeah Queen h4 is totally winning here
King g8 is not playable at all black has
to step forward onto g6 note that in
many situations in the Greek gift there
might be a queen on g4 in this kind of
position and not on f4 in this case we
are we would simply have 96 check a
discovered check that picks up the Queen
or even checkmate so on g7 here this is
not possible a check in fact it's not
possible at all there's no meaningful
one yeah only Queen f5 it is just
dropping the Queen White has to play
with them with a silent move let's say
weather with the preparations and this
makes the sacrifice so far more
sophisticated than the other ones it's
no straightforward check check made now
what is this attacking move white needs
a new unit in their tech age form he's
attacking with Queen Knight and pawn and
you need the pawn as an additional force
once white threat now White has a very
very direct threat a direct win is
threat
how exactly the easiest is to simply
think about what happens if black is
simply not paying attention yeah I mean
okay very unrealistic but let's say it
plays a move like that how do we win h5
is the point yeah black only has two
moves he can take it he can go to h6 if
he goes to aged six
this is winning at least a queen
you can go g5 but this is the check so
no we would like to save it if he takes
this it's even mate Jeff what check very
cute
came back chat check check check check
mate and made yeah very nice so h5 this
is the big threat black has to deal with
that somehow he cannot simply yeah play
any move and hope for the best
how does white conduct the attack f5 is
a move that we can check yeah the idea
is to gain a little bit of space and
deprive white of key attacking squares
like g4
how does white win here yeah he in fact
has Irwin the move rook d4 is immensely
strong again threatening age 5 and then
Queen h4 yeah so if black again is doing
nothing check let's check this check
check check see the point checkmate this
is the reason why this is so such a such
a very strong second set and sacrifice
it is about sacrificing first entry is
then getting all the attacking pieces
into play makes it extremely difficult
to see beforehand you can see that it is
dangerous but to play it knowing that
you're winning missus isn't a leader
thing um if black tries to defend with
this year with Queen to e7 then white
has the Stromboli 610 degree 35 and
further attacks it's very very strong
instead of e-cigs that's also Ruby 3
that should win as well maybe that's
even stronger again having h5 up your
sleeve yeah look educate and rule g3
yeah I mean on a on a very high meta
level let's say there are those two
pieces that do anything for the defense
and this as usual is the key you attack
with pieces wide that have no real
defenders that oppose them yeah there's
the knight on d5 and well it's cool it's
colleague is sitting there on b2 or the
bishop on b7 everyone they're just
spectators and don't really do anything
good for the defense
yeah f5 is not helping Queen d7 this is
an idea
well e 6 is strong takes Queen g4 and
this is very strong now we are
threatening various discoveries but also
rupees 6 and there's really no defense
and something like this check check it's
pretty convincing Derrick I can take it
but check like it's completely falling
apart here
this is threatened this is unprotected
that's totally lost I go back a bit
other moves any other moves that black
and try them yeah one line that's maybe
interesting after Queen d7 as this this
and now not not the king but let's say
the look here but then we take check can
play it like that here we had a pin
that's awkward but he is as strong as
checkmate I made yeah and this means we
just win the house now it's a very
strong attack the best defense actually
was found by tau rooks if one that's the
best defense pull a guy up skip now went
h5 check forcing continuation again
black doesn't have much choice if he
takes it
there's jihad yeah we already know that
idea it's the same thing
check checkmate
the same kind of checkmate so there's
only King h6 neither slack double check
I'm King back yeah this is again check
checkmate
not helping so I'm King back to h7
tragic and now e 6 this is the strongest
continuation it's important to a to take
note that in this case Bishop takes a h7
is an exceptionally strong move as it
leads to a great attack but it is not
completely winning for what it just
leads to a fantastic attack that it's
very very difficult to defend against
and tau didn't admire a good job to
defend this here black only has one move
and it was found by tau Queen to f6 if
black tries to defend with Queen seven
here I mean that was just a threat champ
be true defend try to defend with that
then age six is very strong threatening
h7 mate and this is very awkward now
how should black defend and the only
move to try to defend is Luke h4 after
which White has the fantastic reply
roopd
it's very nice and now well black cannot
take h7 mate and how are you going to
defend against this now I don't think
you'll find anything while also just
threatens to take on h4 and go e7
promoting their pawn it's it's just lost
black has no no defense here if black
tries to oops like take the money and
run say Knight takes D 1 White has a 7
and this will win yeah there is no way
to to defend this I mean from a material
point of view this is interesting still
but you're not saving yourself anyway
here for example 9 times 6 is strong
takes check check
Queen g7 is rook e8 mate and King here
and rook e8 and wins the Queen and the
problem is that very quickly check and
things start to drop and this is not the
final one Yin s more things kind of
unprotected let's go back so the best
defense after the c6 move is not Queen
e7 or 91 but Queen f6 foul by Chara
great defense he wasn't just a great
attacker yeah with his fantastic
calculation abilities he was able to
also defend very well Queen f6 yeah now
white really doesn't have a choice he
has to take yeah there's no big
alternative contigs
and now rook d2 by pulling I have ski
yeah
how should black play now in 1960 by the
way also was a move but rope D to us is
good how should black defend the best
defense the top plate looks e6 right
the best defence probably was looked
before however in both cases he is in
saundra
yeah II seven King takes cat chicks here
age six and black has problems too to
hold that pawn but maybe you still
should have played played that instead
of the game continuation the wait groups
is six and now it gets very problematic
why does taking that here and now we
went to create an alternative was
bishops yet he seven I hope he 898 quite
funny rook here and why it keeps that
pawn
yeah I mean why this of course better
he's a pawn up and he has a dangerous
seven pawn but still black is kind of
hanging on it's difficult to say what's
what is the best defense really because
in all cases flag is in severe trouble
but it's not lost there they are not
really lost all of those continuations
Ruki a despot what are played check
check
Knight f5 took yeah and it's important
to see this is very strong they keep
blacks King out and Luke c7 is
threatened Lucas is six the only move
and now rookie two and black can really
not keep this Hotez together yeah it
just it just too bad check
and now the Knight pawn and rook get a
dangerous check attack going
yeah just took this and now 97 is
threatened this was a very sophisticated
version of the sacrifice on h7 it is
some in many cases a direct win as we
have seen in earlier examples especially
that Yeats game the very first game but
sometimes it's not so straightforward
sometimes the attack is progressing a
little bit differently not here when
white with h4 got a new attacking force
in and only later got his all of his
pieces into the attack this was of
course very difficult to decide upon its
it's made somewhat risky iy is giving up
on giving up a piece of course blacks
King is in grave danger there on g6 but
still you have to do it in this case it
led to a very dangerous attack not a
winning one probably but an attack that
post has so many problems that black
here and it was a very strong player
with tar black could not defend
ultimately so if you can sacrifice on
Age 2 or an age 7 it's a matter of color
of course if you can play such a
sacrifice always consider doing it if
you can
yeah get the King out and get this
attack going it will work quite often
but make sure to check it every time for
specifics there are often little details
that make make a difference yeah don't
be too enthusiastic I got they can
sacrifice now check all the details
there are as I said often there are
nuances that that are very influential
in those in those sacrificial situations
yeah I hope you enjoyed the video make
sure to take on 87 if given the chance
thanks for watching